what we're looking at  is a time when the united states more  than ever  needs a windfall profit tax  on these corporations whether it's the  oil industry  whether it's the grocery stores  manufacturers  car manufacturers doesn't matter  a windfall profits tax  could put an end  to this corporate price gouging that is  crushing americans every time they go  shopping doesn't matter what they go  shopping for  and believe it or not this corporate  windfall profit tax is now supported by  a majority  of american citizens a majority of them  want this windfall profits tax  it's a simple solution  it's a simple solution to a growing  problem that affects the wallets of  everybody in this country rich and poor  alike